dans un petit nombre d'entreprises qui se vendraient plus d'un milliard de dollars.
Cela n'avait pas été créé pour disperser le capital sur de nombreuses sociétés
qui avaient un potentiel de réussite, mais moins important, comme la mienne.
Cela limite le nombre d'idées qui sont financées,
le nombre de sociétés qui sont créées
et le nombre de celles qui reçoivent l'argent nécessaire pour croître.
Et je pense que cela amène une question forte :
quel est notre objectif quant à l'entrepreneuriat ?
Si notre objectif est de créer un petit nombre d'entreprises multimilliardaires,
restons avec le capital-risque, ça marche.
Mais si notre but est d'inspirer l'innovation
et de permettre à plus de gens de créer des entreprises de toutes les tailles,
il faut un autre moyen de financer ces idées.
On a besoin d'un système plus flexible
qui ne confine pas les entrepreneurs et les investisseurs
dans un modèle rigide de retour sur investissement.
Nous avons besoin de démocratiser l'accès au capital.
Durant l'été 2017, je me suis rendue à San Francisco,
pour rejoindre un incubateur avec 30 autres entreprises de technologie.
L'incubateur était censé nous apprendre comment lever des fonds en capital-risque.
Mais quand j'en suis sortie, il y avait un buzz
dans la communauté des startups sur le concept d'ICO, ou Initial Coin Offering.
Pour la première fois, des ICOs avaient levé plus d'argent pour les startups
que le capital-risque.
C'était la première semaine du séminaire.
Vendredi Tequila.
Et les créateurs n'arrêtaient pas de dire :
« Je vais lancer une ICO. »
Jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un dise :
« Et si on en lançait une tous ensemble ?
On devrait lancer une ICO qui agrège la valeur de toutes nos compagnies
et lever des fonds en tant que groupe. »
A ce moment, j'ai dû poser la question évidente :
« Hé les gars, c'est quoi une ICO ? »
Les ICOs sont un moyen pour de jeunes entreprises de lever des fonds
en émettant une monnaie digitale
liée à la valeur et aux services que l'entreprise fournit.
La monnaie se comporte comme les actions d'une entreprise,
comme ce qui se passe en bourse,
dont la valeur monte alors qu'elle est échangée sur internet.
Plus important, les ICOs élargissent le nombre d'investisseurs potentiels,
de quelques centaines de sociétés de capital-risque
à des millions de monsieur tout-le-monde enthousiastes à l'idée d'investir.
Ce marché représente plus d'argent.
Il représente plus d'investisseurs.
Ce qui implique une meilleure probabilité d'être financé.
J'étais conquise.
L'idée, néanmoins, de faire ceci à plusieurs me semblait un peu folle.
Les startups se concurrencent dans la recherche de fonds,
Il faut des centaines de réunions avant de décrocher un chèque.
Le fait que je passe mes précieuses 15 minutes en face d'un investisseur
à parler non seulement de mon entreprise, mais aussi des autres,
était tout à fait nouveau.
Mais l'idée a fait son chemin.
Et nous avons décidé de coopérer plutôt que de se concurrencer.
Chaque compagnie a placé 10% de ses fonds dans un panier commun
que nous avons ensuite converti en une monnaie digitale
que les investisseurs pouvaient acheter et vendre.
Six mois et quatre cabinets d'avocats plus tard...
(Rires)
En janvier 2018, nous avons lancé la toute première ICO
qui représente la valeur de près de 30 entreprises
et une toute nouvelle façon de lever des fonds.
Nous avons fait la une.
Le gros titre que je préfère :
« Capital-risqueurs, lisez et pleurez. »
(Rires)
Notre fonds est par nature plus diversifié.
20% des fondateurs sont des femmes.
50% sont internationaux.
Les investisseurs étaient plus enthousiastes.
Cela pouvait être plus rentable pour eux,
car on supprimait les frais des intermédiaires.
Et ils pouvaient reprendre leur argent, le réinvestir,
et potentiellement financer plus de nouvelles idées, plus rapidement.
Je pense que cela crée un cercle vertueux du capital
qui permet à plus d'entrepreneurs de réussir.
Car l'accès au capital, c'est l'accès aux opportunités.
Et on commence tout juste à imaginer
ce que démocratiser l'accès au capital va donner.
Je n'aurais jamais pensé que ma propre recherche de fonds
m'amènerait sur ce plateau,
après avoir aidé près de 30 entreprises à obtenir des fonds.
Imaginez si d'autres créateurs essayaient d'inventer d'autres façons de se financer
plutôt que de suivre le chemin classique.
Cela changerait ce qui est construit, qui le construit
et les impacts à long terme sur l'économie.
Et je crois que c'est bien plus excitant
que d'essayer d'investir dans une future licorne.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)